le réveil a été chaotique pour de
nombreux canadiens privés de leur
connexion internet en raison d'une panne
majeure du réseau de rogers
communications à travers le pays
beaucoup d'entre eux ont dû faire preuve
de débrouillardise pour commencer leur
journée ce torontois est allé dans un
café pour travailler mais là non plus
pas de connexion internet
ce sera peut-être une journée de congé
je suis certain que mes clients essayent
de me joindre mais qu'il n'y arrive pas
ça m'inquiète un peu dit il vers 9
heures voire jazz a annoncé une panne
sur ces réseaux filaires et sans fil
l'entreprise dû travailler
d'arrache-pied pour rétablir le service
le plus rapidement possible sans
toutefois donner plus de détails
historiquement renvoi d'un pépin comme
ça dans les grosses compagnies de
télécoms c'est souvent un meilleur de
configuration d'équipement ou un
équipement quelconque moi je me ferai ma
même un truc c'est plus quelque chose
quand sow de nombreux services ont été
affectés par la panne des plateformes de
paiement ont par exemple été mises hors
service
à certains endroits il était impossible
de payer par carte de débit ou de crédit
des services de police de la région de
toronto edmonton et de winnipeg ont
quant à eux averti les personnes
abonnées à broders qu'il pourrait leur
être impossible de contacter le 9-1-1 en
cas d'urgence sans compter des bureaux
de service canada qui eux aussi ont été
touchés notamment le service des
passeports
ce qui arrive quand il n'y a que
quelques fournisseurs d'internet tout le
pays est touché non ce torontoise cette
panne majeure la deuxième en 14 mois
pour rogers survie alors que
l'entreprise souhaite acquérir son
compétiteur chaque communication le
projet inquiète notamment le bureau de
la concurrence puisque selon lui la
fusion réduire est le choix pour les
canadiens et entraînerait des factures
plus élevés pour les consommateurs
est ce qu'on peut avoir plus de
compétitions plus de redondance
potasser les choses explosent rips et
des événements comme ça qu'ils vont
faire en sorte que pépé fonction
questionne sur nous nos
télécommunications difficile pour
l'instant d'évaluer l'impact économique
de la fan une chose est sûre elle
causera bien des maux de tête surtout
aux petites entreprises selon cet expert
abou richa cette panne ne sera pas la
dernière croit-il il recommande aux
canadiens et aux entreprises de mieux se
préparer notamment en s'assurant de
toujours avoir plusieurs méthodes de
paiement à leur disposition ils se
rendraient en williams radio canada
toronto